China is home to 1.4 billion people
that means about one out of every five
people around the world lives in China
but the country is facing a population
crisis the Chinese population shrinking
for the first time since the Great
Famine in 1961. China's population could
shrink by 48 percent between now and the
end of the century China's population
decline has really come faster than was
expected it could mean economic
stagnation and it could also mean that
China may never eclipse the U.S as the
world's largest economy
[Music]
to maintain his current population every
woman in China must give birth to two
children in her lifetime
but China's fertility rate has dropped
well below that threshold Urban
households have even lower fertility
rates shanghai's fertility rate in 2022
was 0.7 that's lower than South Korea
the country with the world's lowest
fertility rate
in the past decades China has really
been dependent on this vast labor force
for the economic boom as this labor
force is shrinking will China still have
the same driving force for its economic
growth but also for global economic
growth China's working age population
already started to contract around 2015
or 2016. in the next three decades until
2015 the walking age population can
further draw by 300 million in the
longer term we have fewer people working
by supporting more people in the
retirement less demand there's less
output we're just entering such a
vicious cycle we had the government
Think Tank estimating that the main
pension fund for urban workers will hit
Zero by 2035. it could leave huge
burdens for a lot of elderly people and
their offsprings who are not taken care
of by the Social Security System Beijing
really needs to not only shift growth
model but also it needs to rapidly
increase spending on pensions and health
care if it fails it could mean economic
stagnation and it could also mean that
China may never eclipse the U.S as the
world's largest economy
China's GDP girls can slow from five
percent at present to like two percent
in 30 years so for those who are relying
on China's demand they have to prepare
for slowing China economy this also
means opportunity for some emerging
economies like India who also want to
grow at a fast speed trying to gaining
more share in a global economy they
still have a quite strong population
growth which can be an important driver
for their GDP growth
thank you
[Music]
but for a long time China wanted to keep
his population growth under control as a
shortage of resources put pressure on
the developing country the government
introduced a policy in 1980 that limits
families to have just one child the
government implemented the policy
through fines there's potential loss of
jobs if you are a government employee
but also in many cases forced abortions
and sterilizations
[Music]
foreign the normal Ranch for sex ratio
at Birth is between 103 to 107 male to
100 female since the 1980s this ritual
in China has stayed well above that the
most recent census suggest that there
are over 32 million more men than women
in China
with a lack of female population and
Decades of stringent birth control the
government had reduced the number of
births in the last few decades by 400
million but now they're facing a tough
challenge of reversing that these
demographic challenges have attracted
you know attention from the highest
levels with presidency saying that China
is going to focus on boosting birth
rates and also take a proactive response
to the Aging population so the
government has really reversed this one
child policy at a very rapid clip in
2016 and officially ended that policy in
place of the two-tile policy and even
two years ago when we had then again the
three child policy this is really done
very little to put a halt to this very
rapidly dropping fertility rate
and foreign
[Music]
submissions
China's government especially in the
very top echelons are very much male
dominated one criticism of some of these
policies is that they just fall so
woefully short and they are very
male-centric they're more superficial
responses to very deeply entrenched
social issues that women are demanding
change
um
to ensure that economic growth doesn't
slow with this population drag Beijing
has some tools in its toolkit it can
raise retirement age it can also
encourage people to move from the rural
areas into the cities and it is already
investing heavily in vocational
education as well as in Automation and
Science and Technology
population decline so Global issue we're
all preparing for a world with fewer
population and fewer workers China
probably have you know slowed much
faster than other countries at a similar
stage but I think another economy they
are also seeing a Slowdown in the growth
so in the longer run it's not
necessarily that when China slows other
economies will gained from trying to
decline
foreign
[Music]